today we're going to be speaking with
Christopher key Christopher key is a
political activist a former Fitness
professional and also the leader of a
group called The vaccine police
Christopher maybe you may recognize him
my audience May recognize Christopher
because he has been in the news over the
last year or two for both drinking and
injecting urine for reasons that he will
certainly tell us about Christopher I
appreciate your time welcome
our brother my tie just fell off
well I think we'll be able to persevere
Christopher let me mention just so our
audience I fear no man I fear not saying
let's do it brother go ahead um I will
let our audience know it I believe
you're either recording or streaming our
interview on your end because you are
you don't trust that we'll run the
interview as recorded is that correct
that's what you told me before we
started that is completely correct
brother I trust no no one in the
mainstream at all you guys are
prostitutes and and talking parents but
go ahead good so since we're both
recording it we'll have total clarity as
to what's said so let's start uh when
did you begin to drink urine and do you
drink only your own urine or do you
drink other people's as well
um I drink my own urine brother and
again I did I started this nearly 24
years ago I heard
um a medical doctor talk about this and
I'm like that guy's a crazy nut and then
I heard David avocado woof avocado
David avocado wolf is a good friend of
mine and I heard him talk about it and
David's a little out there but I trust
the man and then I heard a third medical
doctor talk about it and I I I like
everybody I believes that you should
trust your lord and savior and test and
prove all things brother not some things
but all things and I'm like really Lord
I gotta really test and prove piss and I
began to do the research and I got the
book your own perfect Medicine by Martha
Christie and I read through that book
and I'm like oh my goodness brother this
could be real
um and again this is liquid gold and
which you don't understand David well
hold on Christopher I apologize for
interrupting already we have about 15 or
20 minutes and I you know I want to
learn by asking you questions but it has
to be a back and forth so I was just
asking how long you had been drinking
your own urine and whether it's yours or
other people's I think you answered that
so let me I I will mention to my
audience two of the folks that
Christopher mentioned David David
avocado wolf and Martha Christie are
both known medical disinformation
purveyors you can look them up
Christopher and I will disagree about
that and that's okay Christopher I just
am being clear with my audience is that
okay completely understood okay the
second question your question it was 24
years off and on for 24 years and yes
it's my own urine I don't drink anybody
else's urine okay what conditions do you
believe drinking your urine may cure or
prevent
again brother I'm not a medical doctor I
would never practice medicine without
license
um again I tell everybody don't believe
nothing I tell you but do what the Lord
commands each and every one of us to do
no but my question but just what is your
believe me Christopher everybody who
watches this knows you're not a medical
doctor so don't worry about that I'm
just saying what do you believe the
urine does for you
okay well let me go in real quick to
help you understand this you understand
as a layperson that any poison that
comes in your temple your temple
instantaneously creates antibodies yes
or no my temple like the temple in my
head what do you mean you're I call the
temple your body because that's what God
calls it it's the body so do you
understand any poison that comes into
the body your body instantly creates
antibodies that is not my understanding
of the Medical Science but but neither
one of us are doctors right correct okay
good so I'm just cured what is it you're
treating or preventing with the urine
I don't treat to prevent anything
brother I I drink it myself because I
know it's the perfect photonic memory of
when the cells were healthy okay because
I know through Medical Science any
poison that comes to this Temple
instantly the CR the temple creates
antibodies your liver spins it and you
piss it out and I believe all you have
to do is take it back in and let me give
you an analogy real quick if you were to
get bitten by King Cobra you would take
anti-venom correct
I would I don't know I've it's never
happened I don't know what I would do in
a snake bite I'd call my doctor okay
call your doctor and your doctor would
give you anti-venom do you know how they
create anti-venom David
you know I don't I just don't know if
it's relevant to why you take your it's
very it's very relevant okay because the
way they create is very revelant the way
they create anti-venom is they take a
snake whichever snake it is the king
cobra for instance they milk it they get
that Venom they then inject it into a
horse or sheep okay they can inject in
any animal or any person because
instantaneously that animal will create
the antibodies it's now in their blood
so they then re-inject the Horseshoe
sheep pull out the blood because the
blood now has the antibodies they spin
it and that is how anti-venoms created
David okay but Christopher is can can we
is there an answer to the question what
do you believe drinking urine does for
you
beautiful I believe anybody that's
taking the bio weapon are going to be
dead in two to five years and I believe
the antidote for those that have taken
the bio weapons what is the bio weapons
the bio weapon is what they call
covid-19 vaccine it's not it's not a
vaccine it's a bio weapon okay but
Christopher before we get to that before
we get to that and of course many people
received their first vaccine years ago
and they're fine so I don't know if
you'll eventually extend it to five to
seven years or seven to nine but
Christopher I want to wait a second
you've been you've been Drake drinking
the urine 24 years the covet vaccines
have only been around a couple years
prior to the covid vaccines what did the
urine do for you now you're saying it
protects you from the coveted vaccine
but before the coveted vaccine what did
the urine do for you again as I told you
earlier and I don't remember if you
understood or heard that it's the
perfect photonic memory of when the
cells were healthy so I believe any
poison that comes in the temple the
temple creates antibodies the liver
spins it and you piss it out and I
believe one of the best things you can
do is take it back in not to mention it
is billions and billions of stem cells
do you understand you've already drink
your own urine David do you understand
that when you're in your mother's womb
you drink your own urine did you
understand that or no no that's not my
understanding of uh mammalian gestation
but Christopher let me ask you let me
ask you a different question is there
any medical science that supports any of
what you're saying here specific studies
you can point to
yeah I I sent your co-producer a long
list and anybody out there would get the
doctor I mean the the book um your own
perfect Medicine by Martha Christie
there is a lot that book's been widely
debunked as disinformation let me ask
the question a different way is there
can I know you sent Pat a bunch of stuff
but now we're this is the show right the
audience doesn't see what you sent Pat
can you cite a randomized controlled
study proving the efficacy of drinking
urine
again I am dyslexic I'm LD I'm ADHD
um I'm D and Dumber and that's what's so
sad if I can figure this out David why
can't you take the time to do your own
research and your audience do your own
research and understand that the temple
that God created he created it perfectly
you know Christopher this is a show like
it's not it's not super interesting to
be like hey we're doing a show but you
refuse to cite any of the evidence and
tell the audience to Google stuff what
I'm asking is can you cite a single
peer-reviewed study that will tell us
what drinking urine will do versus a
placebo
again I sent all the data to your to
your friend your co-producer yeah I've
given you those clinical studies and um
I mean why can't you put them up on you
know for a click link again I I don't
remember the actual side the reason I
can't put them up Christopher is we
didn't find in going through your list
anything that would meet the standard of
a randomized placebo-controlled urine
trial that proves the efficacy of
drinking urine for any condition
preventing or treating if we if you had
sent us something that met that standard
it would be all over the screen right
now but you're saying you don't remember
them but you've been doing this 24 years
again I told you I'm dyslexic I'm LD and
for me to remember a specific study
number no I sent you the book and again
your own perfect Medicine of Martha
Christie that you're saying it's
debunked or smart enough to go do the
research okay whether it's smart enough
to understand it or not so we'll leave
it at you is it would just so we can
move on is it fair to say you assert the
existence of such studies you're unable
to name them here but the audience can
Google it is that a fair place to just
pause on that so we can move on your own
perfect Medicine by Martha Christie yes
okay you've moved on it seems from only
drinking the urine to also injecting it
is that true
um I have and again I'm not a medical
doctor and I would never tell anybody to
inject Their Own no I know I have
injected my own urine correct what was
the reason hold on a second go ahead
what was the reason to switch from
drinking to injecting
again I drink and I also inject I do
both okay because many your listeners
understand stem cell therapy correct
some of them may but I'm just wondering
why you made the switch
again because I believe urine has
billions and billions of stem cells
especially if you age it okay and
instead of spending 25 to 50 000 going
to Mexico or going to different
countries to get stem cell therapy I've
got my own stem cells in my own urine so
I chose after doing the research to
inject it into my shoulders that I've
had reconstructed is the goal when you
inject to get it into the muscle into a
vein where where are you trying to
inject it
again you're trying to get me to
practice medicine without license and
now no no no no no I'm just asking what
you do I inject it into the muscle but I
would never tell anybody else to do that
Believe Me No One's Gonna Do it based on
you telling anything saying anything on
this show okay so you inject it into the
muscle you talk about aging urine now
this is something that's interesting to
me do you ever I I apologize for the you
know seemingly strange language but do
you ever season or flavor the urine in
any way
um the the Aged urine can be very very
strong so I have added Stevia to it um
to make it a little bit more palatable
Stevie I I would have to kind of chalked
you up to be more of like a manuka honey
type guy
I I like that also but I've chosen to
use Stevia
um when you talk about the
um situation with the covid vaccine
which you've talked about and then just
to be clear just so we're meeting all of
the guidelines of all of the platforms
that we're on uh my views on the covet
vaccine are very clear I believe that it
is a safe vaccine I think the new ones
are not hold on a second Christopher we
each get time to talk I believe that the
the newest vaccines are not effective at
preventing transmission but are
effective at preventing death and
serious illness just to put that on the
record Christopher say that again I need
to hear say that one more time you
believe what well it's I believe all of
the data that I've looked at suggests
that against the newest variants the
bivalent vaccine is very good at
reducing the chance of death from covid
and not good at preventing infection
okay
okay as far as the covid vaccine goes
you and I don't know if you're familiar
with Sherry 10 Penny does that name ring
a bell to you it it does okay you and
Sherry and others have been saying
that tons of people are going to be dead
from the vaccine imminently a thousand
went out over a thousand let me just
finish the question Christopher get on
the playing field and you're not talking
about that hold on Christopher I have to
be able to ask a question I'm being
polite and giving you time let me just
ask my question
every time that you and Sherry say this
sort of thing the time frame is always
just beyond where we are with with
sometimes it's it's six months from now
and now it's been years and everybody's
fine and then it's two to five years Etc
why do you think the timing for the mass
vaccine death always is just a little
bit into the future
it's not brother have you not seen
what's going on with insurance companies
around the world I mean they're showing
you we're having death here in America
like we've never had before okay you
understand that if you take this
bioweapon the number one side effect is
clots microditis Strokes heart attacks
and death that's plain and simple and
you don't Christopher Christopher hold
on a second that's misinformation that's
misinformation the number one side
effect hold on a second hold on a second
let's be really clear the number one
side effect is arm soreness the number
two side effect is a flu-like malaise
the number three side effect is headache
and the number four side effect is fever
that's the truth Christopher are you
willing to admit that
again from the data that you're looking
at those are some side effects but also
blood clot Strokes heart attack death
and myocarditis are side effects would
you admit that yes or no I would admit
that there are some people who have had
myocarditis and pericarditis I don't
believe any have died from it and of
course the odds of that are a fraction
of the odds of muscle soreness is it
fair to say Christopher that when 90
seconds ago you said the most common
side effect is clot are you willing to
admit that's not true that the number
one side effect is muscle soreness
um okay muscle soreness would probably I
I would consider that that okay are you
willing to concede that fever is more
common than myocarditis
that fever is more common than
myocarditis um that is very possible are
you willing to concede that headache is
more common than pericarditis
again you're talking about three very
simple things that can happen with
anything so yeah but Christopher you you
you're the one who asserted that those
are the most common side effects and now
you're admitting that they're not so
that's the big admission from you isn't
it again I believe the the most
things that people need to understand
okay yeah sore arm fever those are all
very very possible but
blood clots Strokes heart attacks
microditis and death is very very likely
and again if dying of covet is less than
one percent of one percent of one
percent and why you would take this bio
weapon that we know we were the
experiment they they told you in the
past Christopher do you see how it's
tough to take you seriously right it's
tough to take you seriously when you
with full and total confidence say the
most common side effects of the bio
weapon are clot heart attacks stroke
death blah blah blah blah and then
within 90 seconds you're admitting hey
you know what what you just said isn't
true what David said is true would you
understand that it's hard to take you
seriously when you say inject urine no I
would not because again you know fever
and muscle armness muscle armness
again I misspoke so excuse me I
apologize okay I'm not as articulate as
you are that's okay okay but I'll try
um I believe again those are common side
effects for any and all shots that you
get okay so I'm telling about true
things that can cause death all right I
got you that this is your this is your
view as a non-doctor okay let me ask you
this you have um entered some locations
including Whole Foods including Walmarts
Etc what do you do when you is it that
you yell things at the pharmacy stuff
what I do let me answer what I do is I
go in and I give them the 11 undeniable
facts regarding all vaccines brother
regarding all vaccines and I put them on
notice okay and once they've been put on
notice if they continue to inject this
bioweapon into the people we can then
hold the them civilly and criminally
liable and it's very likely they will
all be hum because there is going to be
Nuremberg 2.0 brother the the one of the
things you need to understand and hear
me when I say that I've been part of
four national championships three so
super no but Christopher we can't just
steamroll this stuff you've made it
you've made a claim I want to understand
it who's going to be hung under what law
who gets hung here Nuremberg 2.0 is
coming David and those people that
blindly did not do the research and
understand what is happening they Contin
11 undeniable facts do you understand
David in 2010 the U.S Supreme Court
ruled that all vaccines are unavoidably
unsafe and white versus Bristols do you
not understand that I'm not familiar
with that case no but Christopher I
really let me tell you this okay I know
what I know because my greatest
accomplishment in life David is I'm a
father my twins were born with one of
the most rare diseases on the planet
called fennel kitchenoria otherwise
known as PKU where they'll never eat
protein no milk no chicken no cheese no
fish no birthday cake no ice cream
nothing that has protein would they ever
eat if they do it becomes toxic goes
straight to the brain it causes the most
extreme mental retardation David and
because of their rare disease I was
forced like everybody else should be
doing test and prove all things and when
I asked my pediatrician 24 years ago can
you show me the study that this new
schedule safe and he said sure
Christopher they're everywhere and I
said can I see it and he said right now
I said you're damn right right now
you're about to inject my children he
said nobody's ever asked me that but
I'll have it for you by your next
appointment my next appointment David I
went in oh boy and he won't look at me
and he says Christopher there are no
studies but Christopher they have to be
safe you know Christopher um
why are you going to act like that as we
talked about
um before the interview you know we had
about 15 to 20 minutes today and we're
kind of coming to the end of that I
think you actually just maybe told us
the most important thing in this entire
thing and I actually am developing
radical empathy for you Christopher and
I'm going to tell you why you just
mentioned something very interesting you
said your kids have this rare condition
fennel ketoneuria yes sir PKU that is a
condition
that affects many things but it affects
the urine significantly
I actually believe and I feel I feel
empathy for you for this I think it's
possible you've become obsessed with
urine
because of this condition that your
children have which makes the the urine
musty and mousy and I feel really bad
about that Christopher I think that
that's what's going on here is that
possible
no brother it is what's possible here
and problem is I did what my Lord
commands each and every one of you to do
and that is test and prove all things
and when I begin to look at the vaccines
that led me down looking at the food
that's all genetically modified that led
me to look at what they're spraying in
the sky that led me to look at the
poison your government David they don't
love you brother they're not here to
keep you safe and your listeners out
there you may think I'm crazy but
anybody out there that's listening to
David I challenge you these little paint
chips that you laugh about anybody out
there so many people are in pain right
now these little chips they work when we
did the randomized double blind Placebo
studies at my University of Alabama
Christopher people don't even know what
you're talking Christopher just put a
sticker on his forehead which he says
cures pain Christopher listen let's have
you back to talk about the stickers
because we're just out of time I I do I
have feelings of radical empathy for
what is going on with you we've been
speaking with Christopher key he's a
political activist a former Fitness
professional the leader of the vaccine
police and Christopher as I told you we
don't cut these interviews up we're not
going to take you out of context it will
Air as recorded and I really do
appreciate your time today
brother I so appreciate you allowing me
to come on and tell my part of my truth
and anybody out there that's listening
my phone number is
205-936-9803 if you give me your name
address and email I will send these out
for free it'll prove to you that this is
real brother all right Christopher key I
appreciate your time sir
love you don't forget about my Dear
Antler brother the product that was
banned by the NFL the PGA major league
baseball and the NCAA because it works
so well brother all right thank you very
much